we have to mention Braveheart one of
everybody's for everybody how hard was
that for you
it was difficult but I was up there and
immersed among people who all needed
subtitles they'd have to repeat it so
eventually it kind of worked its way
into my lexicon and is it true that Sean
Connery helps you at dinner one night he
did and he we were having we're at and
Eve Anya's place and he's Hungarian
and he made goulash now imagine Sean
Connery saying that word oh it's a Brit
rules with my goo-losh John let's go I
did not know this so I was really waiter
Star Wars Yoda yeah you played Yoda but
on the radio that's right
a year get into this it's a little piece
of Lithgow trivia okay yeah about a year
after Empire Strikes Back came out as a
movie George Lucas produced as a radio
series and he got Mark Hamill and Billy
Dee Williams and a Steve Daniels but
Frank Oz didn't want to play Yoda merely
on the radio I was rehearsing a play
with John Madden at the time John Madden
the film director back then was a
big-time radio director but he was
directing me in a play and he shared the
fact that he just couldn't find anyone
who in and I said opportunist if you
care to find it by god that's me as Yoda
oh my god and a very persuasive it makes
me cry every time I hear
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]